wow everything seems to be happening
really really fast now we just got the
news that one piece will be going on a
four week hiatus after chapter 1053 to
prepare for the final saga and earlier
this week just a couple of days ago i
was convinced that we would still be in
wano for a little bit longer at least
after all that has happened but chapter
1052 of one piece proved me very very
wrong after spending almost two years on
the raid of onigishima that literally
took place over the course of one single
night we have just skipped to a whole
week after the battle just like that i
was convinced that there was still quite
a bunch of stuff to deal with in wano
even after the defeat of kaido and big
mom how kaido knew about joy boy zoro's
connection to wano big moms and kaido's
fate maybe since wano had been taking
its time for the last 4 years roughly i
was kind of expecting things to wrap up
properly and oda sensei taking his time
to say goodbye to the land of samurai
maybe with a couple of other little
surprises happening here after the end
of the battle but boy it looks like now
that kaido has been taken care of we're
trying to get out of here asap a quick
banquet some goodbyes and we're off
towards elbaf or wherever the story
might take us next now if i sound mad or
disappointed about wrapping up one o
this fast i'm actually not but the
sudden shift in speed and pacing has
just really caught me off guard here i
have full trust that oda sensei will not
suddenly start rushing the story now him
taking some time off to properly prepare
for the final saga of the story is a
very good sign actually i think and
honestly people in japan seem to be
thinking the same way as well i actually
covered the big announcement by oda's
editor live on my twitch channel the
other day if you want to check that out
i'll leave a link in the description
below as well and basically everyone
there including luffy's voice actress
tanaka miami speculated that there is
still so so much that has to happen in
the story given all the foreshadowing
that we've gotten over all these years
and anyways this chapter actually closes
a lot of open plot points while opening
up a bunch of others at the same time
and actually want to start with the
ending of this chapter where we finally
finally see admiral green bull ryoku
taking action and making his way to wano
by flying through the air using what
looks like a flower as a propeller this
is a huge deal in a number of ways first
of all it guarantees that we're about to
see his face revealed for the very first
time
we're also about to have one of the
strongest characters in the story make
an appearance in wano the flower on his
back seems to strongly suggest that many
of the plant-based theories surrounding
green bowl were actually true for some
reason it has been speculated for a long
long time now that green bowl might have
a plant-based ability based on both the
colored green and the fact that he
doesn't eat which might have hinted at
that the admiral is using photosynthesis
to actually you know get his nutrition
and stuff and if that is actually true
and this last panel really seems to
suggest that that could mean that green
bowl is a plant logia fruit user someone
whose body is literally made out of
plants which is why he could actually
survive on sunlight alone and girls if i
remember correctly even more
interestingly however is the question
why he's going to hano on his own in the
first place against the will and the
command of akainu who by the way doesn't
seem to have very good control over his
admirals and we're being completely
honest here they all just kind of do
whatever they like now i really don't
know about you but somehow green ball
doesn't give off the vibe that he's
trying to pick a fight with luffy and
cohere if you have to follow my gut
feeling on this i want to say that he
seems much more excited about the fact
that wano has been freed from kaido's
rule that would of course wonderfully
tie in with the idea that both fujitora
and green ball are actually citizens of
wano former samurai that were defeated
by kaido and joined up with the marines
not only would that explain fujitora's
crazy japanese theme and why he blinded
himself seeing all the horrors of mono
but also how the marines were able to
find two such powerful fighters in the
first place lying around guano is pretty
much one of the only places on the
entire grand line where ridiculously
powerful people just randomly live there
was also a lot of speculation that green
bull might be either one of the former
daimyo or even zorro's father either of
which let's be real would be absolutely
epic if true the fact that greenball is
still on his way right now also gives me
a bit of hope that we're not actually
gonna leave wano right next chapter but
that we still have a bit more time to
actually say goodbye to the country of
the samurai and just enjoy the end of
the fight super excited for that and i
can't wait to make a video on green ball
suit as well honestly the next thing we
have to talk about of course is the
gorosei tasking zp0 with capturing and
delivering rob into them now this would
be concerning enough by itself but what
really is worrying me is that robin is
suspiciously absent in this chapter like
completely she's nowhere to be seen
seven days after this specific order has
been given the last time we saw her if i
remember correctly was when yamato
introduced herself to the crew now
however she's neither with frankie and
usopp nor at luffy's sickbed nor in the
pretty wild bathhouse scene that oda
kindly enough threw in this chapter for
us as well we'll we'll get to that in a
while and so the fact that robin is
pretty much the only straw hat missing
in a chapter where her kidnapping has
been ordered by the rulers of the
goddamn world is pretty disturbing the
messaging of this week has all been
about one piece moving into its final
saga
but next to guaranteed arcs like elbaf
lovetale in the final war also setting
up robin getting captured would add
quite a bit of story time on top here i
mean no complaints from my side for more
one piece but rescuing robin from the
hands of the world government
again would be a truly painful and
difficult task for the straw hats that
would take a lot of time i think next up
we finally know who actually died and
passed away during the battle even
though kinemon and kiku seem to be as
good as dead
both of them pushed through in the end
and while i do think that kinemon dying
for momo would have been very powerful
indeed as a moment and i'm sure oda
sensei was thinking about that as well
but in the end getting to see kinemon
actually witness the rebirth of mono and
momo becoming shogun is just way too
precious so i'm really happy we got that
i'm not quite sure if kiku permanently
lost her arm or not we can't really not
see it in this chapter but i'm glad that
she pulled through as well the two
scabbards that actually have lost their
life for goods are shute maru and eso we
actually get this one really sad and
emotional remark by marco who can't
believe he once again survived such a
major battle it must truly paint him for
losing another one of his family members
it was ace and whitebeard the man he
lost during the war with blackbeard i'm
really more than curious to see what
marco decides to do next i really would
love to see him travel with the straw
hats a little bit honestly now i don't
necessarily think that means that he'll
join the crew as a proper member of the
straw hats but simply having him
accompany them for a while would already
be pretty damn awesome but maybe he will
also simply stay in wano for a while and
rest up there we also get some really
interesting closure for the remaining
supernovas drake and hawkins for example
having this closing moment right here
where it turns out that the man with a 1
chance of survival was actually not
luffy or anyone else but hawkins himself
and what i take away from this is that
he apparently knew that luffy would
succeed right from the start but
accepted his fate for feeling guilty
about betraying kids and it does look
like he actually dies here moments later
i think this is actually a really nice
little cathartic ending for his
character
though i do will say that i found
hawkins in general a little bit
underwhelming as a supernova in this arc
in general in the end i guess his role
was kind of being someone with high
ambitions who didn't have kids or
luffy's willpower to actually stand up
and fight against a yonko and in the end
paid for that lack of resolve with his
life both kit and law seem to have been
spending time at the port with usop and
frankie who have been fix him up
everyone's ships it seems it's really
great to see everyone getting along
honestly especially that one panel with
killer and bibble fanboying over shogun
frankie just the best thing ever and
honestly who can blame them it is just
awesome good thing they fixed it what
really caught me off guard in this
chapter though was a poo like don't get
me wrong i'm very much very much on
board for getting the new bounty posters
most likely next chapter i think in fact
i'm working on my own bounty myself
right now trying to overtake trebles 99
million because if you subscribe you
raise my bouncy by 100 berries each and
we're almost at 60 million that's of
course nothing compared to what luffy
and the other straw hats will definitely
be getting after taking down two not one
two yonkos and i'm also really curious
to see who will get the title of yonko
or emperor next to luffy of course will
it be both kit and law will it be three
of them or just one of them after all
there were only two yonkos taken out so
that only leaves two spots open in
theory okay i'm getting a bit too
excited here about the upcoming value
reveal anyways what i actually wanted to
say is that i find it very strange that
appu is just casually walking up to
everyone here and distributing the
newspaper like okay maybe defeating
kaido and big mom has calmed kids rage
and nerves a little bit about being
betrayed but after everything we've
learned about him as a character you
would kind of expect him to like tear a
poo to pieces nonetheless after being
sold out by him and so kid's reaction
here seems off a little bit but maybe
he's just grown that much as a character
during the race or he maybe also is just
way too excited about his new bounty to
still care about a poo in that moment
right now here and then of course we do
have to discuss the preparations for the
big festival first of all i'm still over
the moon that yamato is pretty much
confirmed to be a straw hat at this
point seven days after the battle and
everyone in the crew everyone seems to
love her and treat her as a member
already the fact that she refused to eat
and move for like a week in order to
pray for luffy's health and safety is
just the cutest and most loyal thing
ever it's like a mini version of zorro's
sacrifice and willingness to take on
luffy's pain and suffer for his captain
love it and then the way she rushes in
and hugs luffy is also pure gold the
entire sequence honestly feels very much
like something that could have been
taken place on the sunny momo trying to
pull his usual move with nami and as
expected getting the sanji treatment in
return for it yamato placing a plate on
momo's head actually has him looking
exactly like his father odin i'm a real
sucker for stupid stuff like that it's
just my type of humor and we get a
second serving of the bath house scene
and i honestly think that at this point
oda sensei is either just living out his
wildest fantasies with yamato or is just
really trolling us as his audience
really really badly because yamato as
odin joins all the guys in the men's
section of the bathhouse which of course
has the expected effect on brook and
sanji who basically die of happiness and
in general i think there is a lot of
boob in this chapter i've honestly given
up on trying to figure out yamato's
proper pronoun i'm just sticking with
the beaver card she and my own reasoning
from the last chapter review and i swear
i swear i'm not biased at all because
she just looks super cute but maybe the
biggest surprise of all next to
greenville showing up and the nudity and
robin missing wow this chapter had a lot
in it huh is the fact that zorro seems
to have woken up without any major
repercussions and with the help of yuri
who i'm pretty sure admits in this
chapter that she exploited sorrow being
unconscious there right i really hope
that we still get an explanation for the
grim reaper figure appearing and the
repercussions that zoro should have from
taking the wonder medicine and i also
really love how zorro is secretly
relieved that sanji is back to his old
self after almost losing his humanity
during his fight with queen and if you
really want to understand why this was
such a major moment for his character
you really should watch my video on just
that right here